今日は俺ハトシ
今年で24歳になるポケモントレーナー
今日も世界中にいる不思議なポケモンを見つけて冒険中の全くあった
本器同じみろどこ座にポケモンいないかな
こういうトンネルとかにもポケモンがいるからな
これ変質者かよはずでと疑問のダメなら俺は森の中へでも行くぜ
かっこいいだろでもを疑問トレーナーはお金にならないから気持ちを催しているよふく
堂が変だから子供たちにいじめられる
でも俺は諦めない伝説のポケモンマスターになるまで
tee
シャッポ家もキター
[音楽]
web
さあポケモンスター
止まるぞ
行くぞ
さああああああミンホのやつです
いき求める4
はーいなんだこれくしょん
ええええええ
cjn
スレ ana
def
3種
さあ解けモンスター
きゃろぷらー
こいつは何とか捕まえたいです
茶色ボールます
遠いな
[音楽]
ん
さあ解けモンスターああヘイガニだ
ルビーサファイアの子供のに俺は捕まえたいな
いくぜモーターボールです
[音楽]
はっはっは
掴まれた大
[音楽]
これ
暴くだこれ
これ泊だわー
[音楽]
ん
さっポケモンキター
バンギラスだこいつだけは捕まえなければ
削ぎもマーサーの中すたるです
これはありません
me
総攻撃的な彼ん
[音楽]
すーっ
えっぐん
[音楽]
つじゃ
サーファー
おっだろう
[音楽]
car
teame
ああっああああ
me
me あった
サッポケモ二ター
フェアアームドだ捕まえたい
入った分
いっそちょっとムーン
これでどうだ
ですねそんな飛びますか